so in order to be a great Formula One
driver you need to have the cognitive
capabilities of a chess Grand Master the
strength stamina and reactions of a
fighter and then you also have to have
the endurance of a marathon runner it's
these unique set of skills that would
make it pretty much impossible for an
average human to drive an F1 car
my name is Clayton green and I used to
be F1 performance coach to Sir Lewis
Hamilton back in the 2010 season here's
a sketch of the Silverstone circuit that
I put together silverstones are
particularly unique Formula One Grand
Prix is extremely prestigious it's one
that the drivers find distinctly
challenging It's a Wonderful blend of
high-speed corners and heavy braking
zones and it thoroughly entertains both
the crowd and the drivers when they're
racing
[Music]
so Formula One drivers looking to get
the quickest and best launch that they
possibly can at the start of the race
the average reaction time for an F1
driver is normally around 200
milliseconds Sprint is like Usain Bolt
earlier fraction quicker launching into
a Sprint roughly 160 milliseconds after
the starting pistol but your typical
human being like you and me we tend to
be more around 500 to 600 milliseconds
F1 cars is so fast that just a 200m
millisecond headstock is a driver a 10
meter lead mental composure and quick
references are essential for avoiding
horrific crashes which are all too easy
in silverstone's Hamilton straight where
drivers Go full Pelt before the first
turn
this is the point one driver was hurled
upside down over the safety barriers
last year when another car swerved
toward him from the left
these are the kind of collisions you're
constantly exposed to throughout
Silverstone
and to avoid this F1 drivers train up
their reflexes by exercises like this
where they tap off as many lights as
possible in 30 seconds
an F1 drivers are the best in the world
at this exercise the current world
record is held by British driver Jensen
button who's going so fast he was
averaging two lights per second
now as our lap progresses one of the
bits that drivers most enjoy are the
high speed corners and around
Silverstone we're looking at areas such
as maggots and Becketts where you're
carrying immense speed probably going at
the full speed of the car but doing
still some small but dramatic changes in
Direction
traditionally most of the Formula One
circuits tend to go around in the
clockwise direction if you're turning to
the right it means that the g-force is
going to want to take your head off to
the left you have a force of the
equivalent of like 40 kilos hitting you
in the back of the head that literally
wants to take your head clean off your
shoulders and you've got to resist that
this kind of force would make it
impossible for the average person to
support their own head causing them to
lose sight of the truck ahead and
inevitably crash
Lewis Hamilton and Fernando Alonso both
have neck sizes of 18 inches that's
compared to 15 inches for the average
man and this kind of neck strength
prevents Serious injury the pair had a
near fatal crash last year in the first
lap of the Belgian Grand Prix with Lewis
Hamilton's car experiencing an immense
45g of force Hamilton's neck would have
been hurled in several unpredictable
directions as his car flipped this is
the kind of collision that would give
the average person at best severe
Whiplash and at worst a fatal break
and it's comparable really only to
things like fighter jets and fighter
pilots and the kind of extreme Maneuvers
that they would have to pull in their
planes
now this is an example of a neck harness
it's worn like so you would have someone
literally pulling a force against the
driver's head and they have to tense up
to stop their head from being moved so
the neck musgrature that the neck
training is going to work on for the F1
driver which are going to stop the head
from being pulled forwards or sideways
sternercleidomastoid trapezius muscle
and they're gonna really have to be very
strong and very adaptive to generate
these forces quickly and change
breaking a normal car requires an easy
right or left tap of the car but F1 cars
are another ball game stopping a 4-1 car
requires you to stamp really hard on the
brake pedal and then just bleed the
pressure off gradually the extreme
weight of the g-force means you're
essentially pushing against 100
kilograms or 220 pounds again and again
imagine only using one leg to push up
the weight of a baby elephant hundreds
of times over the course of 90 minutes
you'll be using all the muscles in your
quadriceps in your hamstrings at the
back of the thigh your glutes and also
your calf muscles as well without leg
strength you'd simply be unable to break
the car flying off the track and over
the safety barriers of the first sharp
turn on the Silverstone circuit
thankful
there will come a point at least once in
the race possibly twice and we need to
change the tires coming into the pit
Lane and how do drivers pick up the fact
they need to change tires they use their
inner ear balance or vestibular function
to sense when their tires have lost grip
you might rely on your inner ear balance
to sense when you're going up or down on
a lift for example younger drivers like
Lando Norris who practice on Esports
steering wheels aren't as in tune with
this as older drivers like Lewis
Hamilton drivers such as Lewis Hamilton
are particularly good about the pickup
on those queues and they'll be able to
take you around that in lap as quickly
as possible and get you into your pit
stop even with pretty much zero grip
left on those tires without being able
to sense the loss of your tire grip each
left
basically uncontrolled and dangerous so
the chances of your car swerving out of
control and crashing before you even got
to the pit stop are probably very high
[Music]
as we get into the last quarter of the
race what starts to get you will be the
temperature as it builds up in the body
and the muscular and mental fatigue
Formula One cockpit is quite a unique
environment track temperature could
easily be 50 degrees Celsius the tires
they tend to run at 100 degrees Celsius
the front brakes are running at a
thousand degrees Celsius you've sweated
so much at this point in time you could
easily have lost three to five percent
of your body weight any losses of even
two percent will start to have an impact
on reaction times decision making even
though slight differences will make a
big difference to your overall lap time
and how you finish the race this is an
example of one overall that a driver
might wear the material is fireproof so
very thick and hot in a cockpit that can
reach up to 60 degrees they need the
cardio of an elite marathon runner to
regulate their temperature they need to
have a really well-conditioned car
cardiovascular system because their
heart rate could easily be running at
170 180 beats per minute for the
entirety of a race that'd be around
about probably about 80 percent of most
people's kind of maximum heart rate your
Elite marathon runners would be
sustaining that kind of intensity for a
two-hour Marathon being light and mean
is essential for regulating heat the
average driver is less than 70 kilos or
150 pounds and has less than 12 body fat
a person weighing 90 kilos or 200 pounds
with 20 body fat would struggle to deal
with these harsh temperatures losing
focus and reaction speed in these final
laps ultimately making a controlled
finish impossible
and it's a driver's physical and mental
resilience to these pressures that
ultimately decides the winner
so still see yourself in an F1 car
you might have a bit of work to do first
[Music]